[موسيقى]
الخلافه التجاره السلعيه باحب اركز هنا
برده على تجاره الخدمات تجاره الخدمات
في بعض القطاعات بتفوق بكثير التجاره
الصناعيه
قطاع الخدمات الماليه قطاع الاتصالات
الاتصالات
واجهزه الكترونيه في خدمات اتصالات وبعدين
لا يغيب عننا البعد الاستراتيجي
منافسه دوليه دلوقتي في مجال التكنولوجيا
بصفه عامه
[موسيقى]
من متابعتي للاسلوب اللي بتتابعوا المملكه
في تحقيق توازن استراتيجي ما بين
العملاقين الكبار
باجدن في الحقيقه هذا التوازن مهم جدا من
الناحيه الاستراتيجيه ومن الناحيه
الاقتصاديه بالنسبه للمملكه والخطوات اللي
بيتم اتخاذها في التعاون ما بين المملكه
والولايات المتحده في جانب اخر اعتقد ان
هو بيضع المملكه في في موقف قوي